nothing bothers me more than the rise of
dark patterns
in e-commerce which is an expression for
when designers use human psychology
to essentially trick you into buying
things you didn't know
you were buying so today we're going to
be looking at this uh
this guy who built eleven businesses
three i don't know he could be a great
guy i don't know
but i saw grab my guide for getting
started in real estate i said ooh
let's let's check that out right let's
check it out so i go here
uh i fill up my information okay reverse
wholesaling
uh for how to work backwards so hey hey
can clothe you here and rather than try
to razzle dazzle you and talk to you
about
the thousands of houses we flipped or
any of that kind of good stuff i would
rather just show you how you can do it
right now
that's why i want you to take advantage
of this free book that i put together
for
whoa free pamphlet you mean seems like
it's like 20 pages or something but
that's not the point okay
sorry i'm trying to get you to the point
of what angered me in this video which
is something called
forced continuity which he said he
doesn't do
which we're going to talk about in a
second there's a lie on this page we'll
see if you can spot it
anyway so there's this shipping thing so
you fill in your stuff and i say okay i
want my free book now give me my free
book
and this is where the the the dark
pattern gets involved okay i'm in the uk
today okay so it's one of these free
books that's actually you pay for
so it's free plus 795 domestic shipping
which for a thing as small as that he's
probably profiting
off of the 79.95 so the fact it's free
is a joke but
then there's this is what pissed me off
special bonus round up your purchase by
just
five cents to just eight dollars total
and get access to
three incredible trainings so you're
thinking to yourself great i'll
add in five cents to my purchase right
and there's this long paragraph and most
people when you see a block of text like
this
what do you do you just kind of glaze
over it you're like
you read the headline and you think okay
yeah i guess
and this is where they trick you along
with a free trial to
smart da da da this offer will not be
available any time or place only five
cents
today for seven days then 149
a month are you joking what a dirty
trick huh
this guy he's putting pushing into this
free book which is not free
and he's saying he's probably making
money on the shipping or at least
breaking
even i mean he's definitely not giving
it to you for free in other words
so that's a big joke but then there's
this trick he says add a nickel and what
you're actually doing
is signing up to pay a hundred fifty
dollars every month
and there's even more trickery when you
go to his terms of service like
you have to cancel 24 hours in advance
otherwise
you know he doesn't allow that and then
if you get signed up for the monthly
subscription
then you have to cancel 10 days in
advance of your resubscription otherwise
you get charged
again and this stuff really bothers me
and i think it needs to be called out
whenever
it happens everybody who does this knows
it but they
more think here's the thought i'll get
more sales i'll get away with it
i will get away with it because no one's
here to call me out no one will call me
out
on my crap but i will it doesn't stop
there
because as you go down i saw this thing
that really pissed me off it says there
is no catch well but isn't there though
you're trying to trick
people into getting a hundred and fifty
dollars a month this is a
well-known ux design scheme
it says oh i know there are some
websites out there that offer you
something cool for free but then stick
you with some program that charges your
card every month
this isn't one of them there's no hidden
continuity program
what that's exactly what they're so if
they read this they will be
lied to because there there is no free
trial i thought
this is a five cent trial and then a
hidden continuity program
just a free book if you act now before
my offer inspires uh wondering why
they're doing this
it's because it's my way of giving back
oh what a nice guy because unlike
other gurus i don't make all my money
teaching others how to do the same
i actually run a real business okay so
i'm thinking that this guy's malicious
but what i actually find out cause the
internet detective you guys know me i
had to do some digging
i got out the old magnifying glass i was
like what's going on here you know
and i found something very interesting
i found a very similar phrase on traffic
secrets.com
aka oh big daddy russell
we haven't talked about him yet he's the
he's the progenitor of all the gurus he
teaches them
all his secrets so you come to find out
that i don't think
this guy was maliciously lying for sure
there's a
forced continuity scumbag moving here
but he wasn't maliciously lying
instead he was lazy lazily copying
russell brunson see there is no catch i
know there are some real websites out
there all that kind of stuff
that's straight out of here there is no
catch i know there are some websites out
there that offer you something for free
and then stick you with a program that
charges you every month this isn't one
of them
and russell brunson's by the way is not
this guy who just copy and pasted some
of this stuff
and just replaced it with his business
yeah he does have
a scumbag force continuity thing so i
just wanted to call this out
like i said i mean here's how i think
about things people tell you who they
are
in their marketing if they're a
sleazebag if they're honest
it's very uh obvious they send you
signals
of who they are now i yeah i don't i'm
going to be honest i don't know re
real estate worldwide or whatever this
guy's company's name is i don't know
them
but when i see the marketing i see how
it's structured i get a certain
opinion of this company and i think uh
yeah be better okay be better than this
in your marketing be better
than this in your funnels guys come on
this is pathetic this is very easy
to spot it's not a good luck anyway
that's all i wanted to say just wanted
to call this out real quick
little coffeezilla quickie thanks for
watching i'll see you in the next
[Music]
was where you one me wake up and smell
the coffee